from the air the true extent of these
floods and landslides can be seen this
helicopter is on its way to the region
of Lebec where dozens of people were
buried and communities cut off medical
aid and food supplies are being flown
out to the tens of thousands of people
who have lost their homes or simply
can't get back to them monsoon rains
that started on New Year's Eve have
unleashed the biggest flash floods in
the region in a decade rescuers are
finding more bodies and emergency
shelters are filling up in the capital
Jakarta this sports hall has been turned
into a temporary home but it can only
hold a few hundred people at least
170,000 across the city need shelter but
a Girl Scout leaders in a dress children
he looked very sad when they arrived
there traumatised seeing the floods and
their parents panicking in areas people
can return to a cleanup is underway but
it's a major challenge entire suburbs
are submerged some places are 19 feet
underwater with more rain on the way the
government has become seeding clouds the
process of pumping certain chemicals
into the air in an attempt to prevent
rain across flood affected areas the
peak of the rainy season is in February
and March so we're still facing possible
floods we're now modifying weather so
the rain won't fall in the cities for
the people whose houses are flooded we
hope they'll stay in refugee compounds
so we can monitor their health and
reduce possible disease the hope is that
floodwaters recede before the next rains
arrive Nicola gage al Jazeera